[Music]
well hello dear friends Welcome to our
favorite program I'd like to know uh
wherever we go people say that this is
their favorite program and it's ours as
well because we learn a lot as we do
research we want to welcome you I'm here
with Pastor Salasar who's on our staff
uh in charge of our Hispanic work here
at Secrets unsealed and I'm Pastor
Steven bore president of Secrets
unsealed thank you for being with us and
we want to let you know which address
you can send your questions to TV at
some tv.org you'll see it on the screen
TVM tv.org and we want to have prayer
before we start answering questions
Pastor salad would you pray please
absolutely let us pray Heavenly Father
we thank you Lord for giving us another
opportunity to be able to study your
word and to seek the answers to the
questions that many of our friends have
in your word in your scriptures we pray
that you will give us discernment and
again Inspire us with your holy spirit
so that we be able to share and uh give
the answer that will bring PE people
closer to you and to a closer and clear
understanding of your word we pray this
in Jesus name amen
amen well our first question comes to us
from Junior
M uh he's from Namibia
Namibia and it's a very short questions
but U I've seen it before uh this is
what it says my name is Junior M an SDA
Believer from Namibia but just want to
ask a question that where was Satan when
God created Adam and Eve what started
first was it the casting down of Satan
that is the fall or was it creation so
what can we say about this well Pastor
Bor it's a good question the one that
I'm I'm assuming I'm very sure that our
friend Junior has been wondering since
in the Bible we have verses that present
us the events that happen in heaven for
example Revelation 12: 7 it speaks there
that the was war in heaven and Michael
and his angels fought against the dragon
and the dragon was cast out with the the
with the third um with a dragon with his
tail that was covering the the stars of
heaven and so this example this verse
tells us of that war in heaven between
Michael and
Lucifer and yet it doesn't really tell
us specifically in that verse when it
happened so obviously somebody that
reads the Bible is wondering when when
did that happen happened it happened
before creation or happened after the
fall or after creation and so in this
example this one that I think it's
better to go to the spr prophecy where
we can actually get a a very clear uh
definition on when it happened in the
book for example story of redemption
it's in the chapter or first chapter and
in the page 18 and 19 we have the
sequence of events clearly defined there
and I'll read the parts there so that we
can actually understand when it happened
she says there then there was war in
heaven the Son of God the prince of
heaven and his loyal Angels engaged in
conflict with the arch Rebel and those
who United with him the Son of God and
true loyal Angels prevailed and Satan
and his sympathizers were expelled from
Heaven all the Heavenly hosts
acknowledge and adore the God of Justice
not aain of rebellion was left in heaven
all was again peaceful and harmonious as
before angels in heaven mourned the fate
of those who had been their companions
in happiness and Bliss their loss was
felt in heaven so here in this first
part we see that there was war and they
were expelled from Heaven it doesn't
tell us if they were sent to Earth and
this is the next uh paragraph the father
consulted his son in regard to at once
carrying out their purpose to make men
to inhabit the Earth he would Place men
upon probation to test his loyalty
before he could be rendered eternally
secure so here we see that after the war
in heaven after there was this fight
this conflict and the angels of God and
Michael of course Jesus expelled Satan
from heaven then is when the Lord or the
Father and Jesus starting the work of
creating the Earth so the angels of
Lucifer I mean Lucifer Satan and his
angels were expelled before creation of
the world before men was made and they
were not cast directly to the Earth
either the only place where they could
have access to tempt man was in the tree
of knowledge of Good and Evil that's the
only place so where were the Angels when
they were expelled of heaven where were
they where did they go well they just
sort of I guess roam the universe
looking for a place to to to to inhabit
but really this is how the sequence of
events are so there was definitely uh
the war in heaven Satan is spelled out
from Heaven the Earth is created by God
the father and the son of course and
then the F comes and Satan sort of
overcomes men in Temptation and he then
claims the Earth as his own and of
course the controversy originated in
heaven right over the creation of man
mhm that's what made Lucifer jealous
yeah uh early writings page 145 says but
when God said to his son let us make man
in our image Satan was jealous of Jesus
right he wished to be consulted
concerning the formation of man and
because he was not he was filled with
Envy jealousy and hatred he desired to
receive the highest honors in heaven
next to God so he aspired to uh take a
higher position than Christ absolutely
and then of course that led to war in
heaven uh it took a while yeah Ellen
White says in Patriarchs and Prophets
that God bore long with Lucifer in
heaven so at that point he still hadn't
created this earth right once they're
expelled then he decides to go forward
with the plan right right praise the
Lord very good I I think that that
pretty much clarifies the question uh
here we have another one this is from
Neville and uh the question is this I
saw all that would not receive the mark
of the beast and of His Image in their
foreheads or in their hands could not
buy or sell this is Ellen White quote I
saw that the number 666 of the image
Beast was made up and that it was the
Beast that changed the Sabbath and the
image Beast had followed on after and
kept the Pop's and not God's Sabbath and
all we were required to do was to give
up God's Sabbath and keep the
popes um and then we should have the
mark of the be beast and of His Image uh
so that's a el white quotation and the
question is does this mean that the
number 666 should be attributed to the
United States of America as opposed to
the papacy well um I think that's
important Pastor to really look at that
through also in the Bible you know how
they describe what that you know what
the verse actually says about the 666
and I'll just go briefly back to
Revelation 13 where we find this element
and it mentions here uh as we're going
to verse
18 it says here is wisdom let him that
un had understanding count the number of
the Beast for it is the number of a man
and his number is 600 three score and
six or
666 uh this verse is telling us that the
number is associated with the Beast now
what Beast is this one that we're
speaking of some people have argued that
it has to be like in this case using
this this quote maybe it's in regards to
the second beast that we have there that
creates the one that rises out of the
sea but if we go by that uh particular
thinking we actually realize that the
last experience or the last uh entity
that is mentioned is actually the image
of the Beast the image of the Beast is
the last U entity mentioned and the
image of the Beast is basically a
attribute to the first Beast right to
the papacy not to the second beast is to
the first Beast to the papacy so when we
look at the number of the Beast is
linked to that last entity which is the
image of V which is linked to the papacy
this is why it's important to follow the
you know the sequential understanding
and see that it's dealing with the image
of the Beast which is linked to the
first Beast which is for the papacy so
Sunday sacredness which is the the mark
of the beast which is going to be the
entity of the image of the Beast that
experience it's really a a a connection
to papacy and therefore 666 is linked
directly to the
papacy very good I don't know that
excellent answer I hope that uh that uh
brother Neville has been watching the
program we have this answer uh the next
question has to do do with the parable
of the weed and the
tears and um it's kind of long but let
me just go ahead and read it uh
greetings God bless your ministry and
each of one of you my question is
regarding the parable of the weed and
tears to be more specific can tears
become wheat and wheat become
tears when we read the book Christ
object lessons Ellen White explains the
meaning of this Parable she defines the
wheat as those who are con converted by
the Holy Spirit on the other hand the
tears represents those who join the
church but lack the true convis of
conversion of heart uh you Pastor bore
agree on this matter I saw your video
presentation about it and I also read
your PDF document the end time dimension
of The Parables I understand that this
Parable also represents the cosmic
conflict the point is this how about if
one of the tears really repents and
truly serves Jesus in this case he or
she would become wheat on the other hand
How about if one of the wheat departs
from Jesus stays in church but becomes
lukewarm and acts as a tear would not
these two hypothetical scenarios mean
that wheat become tears and tears become
wheat I like the fact that uh that the
person who asks this question which is
Avis MH um like the auto rental company
uh this person uses the word
hypothetical hypothetical yes uh you
know the parable itself doesn't tell us
whether the wheat can become a tear or
the tear become a wheat um you know we
would have to guess we would have to
create a hypothesis which is not based
on absolute fact well you know Pastor b
i I think and I want to um find I'm
trying to get to the to the actual
Parable because I think there is an
element that even though parables are
like you said hypothetical in a sense
that there are illustrations and
experiences that we cannot in every
single thing take it to a confirm um you
know definite decision or or defined
experience as they are examples or
illustrations of teaching something I I
believe that it's important that in the
parable of the weat and tears we
actually realize that the decree of
the you know the owner of the field
which is represents
God uh or or or Jesus is that we don't
touch that the serpents don't cut the
Wheats from the tears until they are
matured until they are of age and show
their fruits so we could say that we
don't know who ter or wheat are right
now until there is that Harvest there is
that element of of of of finally giv
fruits so in the process could one
change at the other maybe as they grow
one can become a thir ultimately what
I'm saying with this is that even the
parable sort of defines that the moment
of defining who really was one or the
other happens at the Harvest at the you
know end not at the beginning so we
can't really say that whoever is right
now or appears to be a tear is going to
be really a tear forever it might be
that they're growing in the experience
that's what I would CH it's possible you
know any answer that we give would be
hypothetical yes because the parable
doesn't exactly address this particular
question right um you know there is a
possibility of conversion of people yes
even you know you take Saul of Tarsus
for example he was pretty nasty guy yeah
I mean uh I would say that for a while
he was a tear
maybe but but the parable doesn't
address it but I have a strong suspicion
that once a tear always a tear and once
wheat always a wheat uh according to the
the end of the parable like you're
mentioning of course and and and God of
course in his infinite wisdom and
understanding knows the very end of the
person that you know the defining
decision but at the same time uh I think
that like I said the parable is not so
defined that we have to think of in a
hypothetical thing you know a scenario
instead of Define scenario okay sorry we
couldn't be more definite on this uh you
know for a but uh you know when we don't
have a clear thus sayith the Lord in a
parable or a question we have to just uh
hypothesize I yes okay the next question
comes to us from po
p he's from Botswana in Africa but
currently residing in Perth Australia
I've been there it's a long ways it's
way over on the other side of Australia
going from here the other side it seems
like you're travel forever but anyway uh
this is the question hello pastors I
would just like to thank you for your
wonderful program now I'd like to know I
am currently studying the Seven Seals
anchor program by Pastor bore in the
second lesson from the series he
mentions that the casting down of Satan
as mentioned in Revelation 12 has a dual
application that is first when he was
cast out of heaven with one-third of the
Ang Angelic host
and second when he was cast out as the
representative of Earth from heaven at
Jesus death can you kindly provide
evidence biblical and spiritual prophecy
for the latter
submission uh maybe I should uh address
this because uh he referring to my study
notes absolutely um basically in
context Revelation 12 m is describing
the casting out of Satan the
cross uh and there's a structural uh
study that I've done which shows this we
won't get into the structural issues now
but how do we know that this is
referring uh to the casting out of Satan
at the cross well let's read carefully
Revelation CH 12 and let's begin at
verse 10 okay it says there and I heard
a loud voice saying in heaven now is com
salvation and strength and the kingdom
of our God and the power of His Christ
for the accuser of our Brethren is cast
down which accused them before your God
day and night okay so verse 10 says that
at that when he was cast out before that
there were Brethren to accuse mhm
originally there were no Brethren to
accuse right uh because the angels are
never called
Brethren so the Brethren are those who
are converted Jesus says my brothers and
my sisters are those who do the will of
God so one hint is that um he had been
accusing the Brethren MH before he were
cast out yes so it must refer to
something that takes place much later
than the original casting out and then
there's another detail in verse 11 if
you want to read verse 11 yes it says
and they overcame him by the blood of
the lamb and by the word of their
testimony and they love not their lives
unto them
so at this point the blood of the Lamb
has been
shed and that cannot be said at the very
beginning right it says they overcame
him the Brethren who had lived before
Jesus died on the cross they overcame
him by the blood of the Lamb so these
are clear indications that In this
passage we are dealing with uh an event
that happened at the cross now we have
further evidence of this in John 12 that
there are two casting out castings out
of Satan right uh the first of course is
Isaiah chapter 14 you know was cast out
of heaven with his angels as it says in
the Book of Revelation so in John 12: 30
to 33 is the casting house casting out
at the cross it says
there and Jesus answered and said these
voice came not because of me but for
your sakes now is the Judgment of this
world now shall the prince of this world
be cast out and I if I be lifted up from
the earth will draw all men andto me and
lifted up refers to his hanging on the
cross so he says uh you know um I'm
going to I'm going to um actually uh
save human beings on the basis of My
Sacrifice and that casts out it clearly
says now the ruler of this world will be
cast out correct so he was cast out and
then there's another Avenue and that is
what we find in Luke 18 and verse 10
Luke 18 and verse 10 uh very very
interesting what we find here Luke 18:10
yes uh actually 1018 not 18 but yes 10
1018 1018 yes thank you no words Pastor
it's been a long day I know it's been a
long day so it says here and he said
unto them I be beheld Satan as lightning
fall from
Heaven okay and now I'll read from Ellen
White because the person that asked the
question says we um provides whoever PO
is ask for evidence from the spirit of
Prophecy uh in Bible
commentary uh P Volume 5 page 1150 it
says when Christ cried it is finished MH
God's unseen hand rent the strong fabric
composed ing the veil of the temple from
top to bottom the way into the holiest
of all was made manifest God bowed his
head satisfied now his Justice and mercy
could blend he could just he could be
just and yet the justifier of all who
should believe on Christ he looked this
is the father he looked upon the victim
expiring on the cross and said it is
finished the human race shall have
another trial the Redemption price was
paid and Satan fell like lightning from
heaven so uh once again uh when Jesus
said it is finished Satan fell from
heaven like lightning uh so uh John 12
Luke
10:18 plus uh what we find in the spirit
of Prophecy clearly shows that uh there
was a casting out originally that was he
was physically cast out and at the cross
he was cast cast out as the ruler of
this world and Ellen White emphasizes
that he was also cast out fully and
completely from the sympathies of the
Heavenly beings because they still had
questions and they were a little bit
confused until they they saw the way
that Satan treated Jesus and then any
Little Bit of Sympathy they had with
Satan was totally taken away absolutely
pastor and also you know to add to that
it's that Satan also lost that
representation of Earth if you will you
know remember that in in the Book of Job
he actually goes as the own or
representative of the earth as the one
that goes before the father and though
he had this access to Heaven up to that
point but when he actually was this you
know uh overcome by Christ at the dead
of the Cross he lost the claim he had to
this world and Christ redeemed and
regained The Authority the full
authority over this Earth and so no
longer he is no longer the prince of
this world but he becomes the well the
the one that lost you know the battle
with Christ and Christ became the
rightful heir to what this world is you
know for his and that's why Jesus is
called the last
Adam because Adam was the original
representative that lost his position
but Jesus as the we say the second Adam
the word second is not used but it's
implied right you know Jesus as the last
Adam came and undid what the first Adam
did and uh and so you know when when the
Bible calls Jesus the last Adam we know
that he is now the representative of
this world Satan no longer can lay claim
to this world because Jesus by his death
bought it back and this is important
Pastor B because you know this this
concept of Adam you know Jesus being
named the second or the last Adam it
really helps us understand that is not
use the word Adam for for him to because
of the same nature as Adam is not
nothing to do with the nature of Adam
but actually the role of Adam having
been made as representative of this
world as the one that is was to rule
this world was the one that was to be uh
responsible for this world right as he
now Jesus overcame the enemy and the
cross he becomes the last Adam
indicating the title the example of him
being our representative the owner the
rightful owner to this world is now
Christ and so it becomes clear that way
and not so much in the sense of the
nature of of of Christ as being like
right it's not dealing with this human
nature exactly which is important well I
wish we had time for another question
but time is just about up uh I just want
to encourage you to please send your
questions to us uh you know we we thrive
on your questions unless we had
questions we wouldn't have any program I
know so we do appreciate every question
there's no such thing as a bad question
every question that we receive is a good
question and um we receive them in order
in other words we don't go to the back
of the line uh and answer the questions
uh you know in disorder we you send us
your questions we uh put them all in
order we do the research and then uh in
the program we try to answer the
questions how much time do you do you
dedicate to uh uh to this program a week
do you think well we dedicate several
hours pastor we have to you know study
make sure that we understand ourselves
the questions sometimes the questions
that really hard to to grasp and so it
takes time but we are thankful for the
opportunity to study the word and we
rejoice in the fact that we can uh learn
as well as praise the Lord yes and we
thank you for your prayers and also for
your financial support you know it takes
a big team to produce programs like this
we appreciate your prayers number one
and your financial support thank you so
much for joining us God bless you and we
hope to see you next time and I'd like
to know
[Music]